Tehát ezeket mindenképp emelném. Tehát
itt a tényközlés ugye, tehát szürkévé
vállok a másik személy számára. Nem
leszek annyira unalmassá szürkévé, nem
leszek annyira megtámadható, hogyha ezt
így próbálom meg milyen a szürke szikről
kommunikációban. Ö
tényekről beszél, röviden,
tömörmondatokba, tőmondatokba beszél.
Igen. Nem lehet, hogy csak egy emojsival
reagál egy üzenetre. Egy oké, vettem az
adást egy lájkal, hogy vettem az adást.
nem megy bele érzelmi beszélgetésekbe.
Tehát emlékszem, nemrég valaki átküldött
egy kis üzenet másolatot és nagyon mély
érzelmi megnyilványulása volt az
egyénnek, aki írta az üzenetet annak,
aki megmutatta nekem, és kérdezte, hogy
mi a véleményem, hogy én erre hogyan
reagáljak. És elmondtam, hogy két út
van. egyik az, hogy érzelmileg
kapcsolódsz az ő reakciójához, ami egy
ilyen önigazult
üzenetről tanúskodott, meg hogy ős ő jól
csinált mindent, meg hogy ez a
grandiózitás, meg hogy minden ott volt
benne. És mondtam, hogy van az út,
amikor érzelmileg reagálsz, és megértően
reagálsz, de akkor ő tovább fog téged
provokálni.
[Zene]
لا